hey 42 here in Japanese culture anime is
a revered artistic medium enjoyed by men
and women young and old and more
recently on every continent anime
transcends cultural boundaries and can
be used as a vehicle to tell any kind of
story imaginable the great anime aren't
just quality entertainment they can also
offer cutting social commentary
philosophical musings and much much more
not your grandfather's Saturday morning
cartoons to be sure thanks to Japanese
artists who are determined to show you
just how fur matically deep the realm of
animation can be let's take a look at
some interesting facts you might not
already know about anime
around 60% of the world's cartoon
animation entertainment is Japanese
produced anime the first wildly popular
anime was a salute asuka's Astro Boy in
1963 Astro Boy was also the first
animated television series in Japan
Tezuka was greatly influenced by
Disney's work during the Golden Age of
animation as were many of to zookas
contemporaries he followed up with
another hit Kimba the White Lion which
in turn is seen by many to have inspired
the Disney classic The Lion King
inspiration coming full circle early
examples of Japanese animation in the
20th century were inspired by animators
in America and Europe and most were
adaptations of Asian folklore and
legends in traditional Japanese art
styles science fiction based mecha anime
also known as giant robot anime was one
of the first genres to really catch on
with viewers during the anime boom of
the 70s foundational mecha shows such as
Mobile Suit Gundam paved the way for the
modern anime industry and blazed a broad
trail for others to follow though anime
has a reputation of not catering to
Western sensibilities regarding violence
on sexuality the mid 90s series Neon
Genesis Evangelion
certainly tested the limits of what was
considered acceptable due to the often
shocked
and controversial content of Evangelion
TV Tokyo began heavily censoring
subsequent anime like the acclaimed
Cowboy Bebop
resulting in only half of the episodes
produced for the space Western ever
airing on television akira is widely
considered to be one of the most
influential works of anime ever created
introducing anime to the Western world
when it burst onto the scene in 1988 the
sci-fi spectacular is said to have been
a strong source of influence for the
filmmakers behind modern sci-fi films
such as The Matrix Chronicle and looper
the 1995 cyberpunk hit ghost in the
shell' is another visionary anime which
inspired artists around the world
the Wachowski also drew upon ghost in
the shell' during the development of the
matrix whilst James Cameron and Steven
Spielberg are both outspoken fans of the
anime many anime begin life as manga a
popular form of printed media in Japan
which has many similarities of the
Western comic book though in Japan manga
doesn't suffer from the same stigma
because it's enjoyed by people of all
ages after an anime gained enough
popularity feature films and video games
typically follow as well in Japan more
paper is used to print manga than to
make toilet paper Hiromu Arakawa Full
Metal Alchemist is one prominent example
of a manga which spawned an anime due to
its popularity though it bears the
distinction of having two fully realized
separate anime adaptations of the story
that don't actually agree on what the
ending should be the first anime began
production whilst Iraq era was still
hard at work on the manga and it caught
up to her before she finished with her
approval it diverged midway through the
story and followed the animes unique
plot threads to their own conclusion the
second anime Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood began production during the
final chapters of the manga and
faithfully adapted the source material
all the way to the end in an unusual
turn of events the wildly popular
Pokemon franchise first appeared on the
scene
as a videogame with the manga and anime
following afterward many episodes of the
Pokemon anime have been banned in
countries other than Japan one
particularly infamous episode has been
removed from circulation worldwide after
causing hundreds of seizures the episode
named electric soldier porygon has been
recognized by the Guinness Book of World
Records for the most photosensitive
epileptic seizures caused by a TV show
the Dragon Ball franchise has gone both
ways between manga and anime with the
Dragon Ball and Dragon Ball Z anime
being adapted from the original manga
whilst Dragon Ball GT and Dragon Ball
super were fit to the printed page after
the anime had aired it is common for
fans of anime and manga in Western
countries to refer to themselves as
otaku a Japanese word for people who are
wholly consumed by their interests
though at a glance it might appear
similar to the relatively mild English
words geek and nerd otaku is in fact
viewed by the Japanese as a sort of
warning for individuals who obsess over
things to an unhealthy degree and
deserve their often self-induced
ostracization from society expect some
disgusted looks if you announce yourself
as otaku in front of someone born and
raised in Japan many animes receive a
localized dog when they are released
internationally with re-recorded
dialogue for the new regions but this is
no small feat in most cases the script
writers must meticulously crafting log
which matches up of the existing lip
movements of the characters on screen as
the animation work has already been done
anime characters are known for their
large bright eyes and extremely vibrant
hair colors but their rind hair colors
aren't just plucked out of the air in
Japan colors have great symbolic meaning
and the hair color of anime characters
is carefully chosen by the animators to
reflect that characters personality for
example characters with red hair are
typically passionate feisty adventurous
and highly opinionated a green hair
represents trustworthiness and tolerance
but also jealousy Whitehead characters
are usually mature ethereal and magical
one of the most beloved anime studios
around the world is Studio Ghibli which
has over 93 production credits spread
across three decades 20 of which are
feature films
Hayao Miyazaki and ISO Takahata Ghibli's
founders named the studio after the hot
dusty and often rainy winds which blow
across the Mediterranean from the Sahara
the Arabic word for the wind was
mispronounced as Ghibli and ultimately
it became Ghibli as we know it today
Mya Zaki has directed many of the
studio's most successful films and he
has been dubbed the Walt Disney of Japan
due to his impactful and storied career
like Disney Maya Zaki wasn't afraid to
wade into the nitty gritty work of
animated filmmaking during his long and
illustrious career with Ghibli he took
on many different roles to bring the
stories to life working his animated
director produce a storyboard artist
writer and editor whilst directing films
Maya Zaki maintained a hands-on approach
often personally inspecting the key
animation and redrawing it when it
didn't meet his high standards the famed
director also laments the state of the
modern anime industry noting that many
people who work in the fry egg industry
quote-unquote don't spend their time
watching real people and can't stand
looking it over humans which he
speculates is because the industry is
full of otaku diehard fans of anime with
pipe dreams of making their own intern
perhaps she's onto something besides art
an offer of maya sakis passions is
flight he acquired this interest from
his father who ran a company that
machined parts of Japanese aeroplanes
during world war ii planes and other
flying machines are featured prominently
in Maya sakis works many Ghibli films
like The Secret World of Arrietty and
pom Poko are simply masterful retellings
of older folk tales such as the
burrowers and Japanese folklore
regarding tanuki spirits as the saying
goes good artists borrow great artists
steal but the truly great artists can
bring the familiar
to life in exciting new ways my izaki
spirited away was the first anime to
ever win an Academy Award taking home
the goal for Best Animated Feature of
2002 spirited away is also the
highest-grossing Japanese anime film of
all time earning studio ghibli 330
million u.s. dollars in revenue
worldwide as animated films began to
explore the use of 3d animation and
strong CGI elements Studio Ghibli was
determined to continue producing films
using traditional methods of animation
only using computer-generated imagery to
touch up the hand-drawn work Princess
Mononoke was one of the first Ghibli
films to feature prominent CG our John
Lasseter chief creative officer of
Disney Animation and Pixar
has fostered an enduring friendship with
Hayao Miyazaki the two met in 1987
whilst Lasseter was visiting Japan with
each having great respect for the
other's work whilst not quite a rivalry
they have been a source of encouragement
to one another with John noting that
whenever we get stuck at Pixar or Disney
I put on a my a Zaki film sequence or
two just to get us inspired again the
friendship between Disney and Ghibli
goes even deeper with a 1996 deal
between tokuma shoten publishing and the
Walt Disney Studios granting Disney the
exclusive honor of serving as the
international distributor for Ghibli
films this includes dubbing the English
versions of the film's a task which
Disney takes quite seriously
thanks to the house of mouse many
high-profile actors and actresses have
lent their voices to the English dubs of
Ghibli movies Cate Blanchett John
Ratzenberger Christian Bale Matt Damon
Tina Fey and Liam Neeson just to name a
few have all given their own personal
spin to classic Ghibli characters and
new species of velvet worm discovered in
Vietnam in 2013 was given the scientific
name yo para Potter's toe Taurus as a
nod to Studio Ghibli's my neighbor
totoro due to the worm and the cat boss
appearing visually similar because of
their many legs located just outside of
Tokyo in the
Mitaka there is a museum dedicated to
all things Ghibli where visitors can
meet an almost life-size tuturro besides
other popular Ghibli characters and
exhibits Hayao Miyazaki speaking is the
museum's executive director hope to
create a place that is interesting and
which relaxes the soul somewhere that
quote-unquote those seeking enjoyment
can enjoy those seeking to ponder can
ponder and no seeking to feel can feel
echoing sentiments felt in every frame
of his films though Mizuki has claimed
you have retired several times during
his career he announced yet another
retirement in 2013 stating that this
time I am quite serious citing
age-related issues with the workload
whether he returns to create more
masterpieces or simply enjoys his
retirement remains to be seen but no
matter his decision he has certainly
earned his place in history thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42